Now what I'd like to do is just, to kind of help us think through this.
I'm going to show you a whole lot of examples to cover the space of
what it means to go from different values of the exposure triangle.
Let's take f number 5.6.
And I will start off with a shutter speed of one over ten.
This is the same scene.
And of course, because of the fact that the apertures open for a while.
And I'm also keeping the shutter speed.
There is a lot of light entering the sensor.
This image might be refered to as over-exposed.
Same aperture value.
I've now basically gotten the shutter to work at one one-twentieth,
twice the speed of this.
Twice as fast.
Of course here you can start seeing that image is less over-exposed
then this one.
I'm going down again, doubling the shutter speed.
Doubling it more.
And now you can start seeing that this image actually seems to have
less overexposure than any one of them.
But I keep on going there to one one-sixtieth.
Same aperture value.
Now it might start getting darker.
More darker.
Even more darker and now we are getting into the range of underexposed.
For those of you interested, we may actually now start thinking about
what would histograms of these images would look like.
Based on the lecture we looked at before.
Darker image, nothing like this, this would be.
Overexposed, underexposed,
extremely underexposed because now we really can't see any details.
Let's now actually move up and down these axes.
So now, I'm actually going to take this speed,
one over one-hundredth of a second.
And then I'm going to go in and actually give it an f number of 4.0.
F 5.0.
This was 5.6.
7.1.
9.0.
13.0.
And 20.
Again, you can see what the impact was.
It was, these of course the images are much smaller.
So you can't details of the depth of field kinds of stuff here.
But this seems to be a nicely exposed image.
A little over-exposed, but fine.
But as you go on increasing the aperture size, oh sorry, decreasing
the aperture size, we notice that now we're getting a lot less light in there.
So here, we went this direction and we basically make the shutter speed faster.
And here we went down this way and basically made the aperture smaller.
These two are underexposed.
These two are overexposed.
We can imagine actually filling this complete matrix out, but
that would have been a too crowded of a slide.
I just wanted to show you the impact of all of this.